and you know this anger you get from
women this is like the sign of a
controlling wife I'm gonna I'm gonna
because that's like spite anger and it's
not any you know understanding to where
guys are coming from and that's really
what I'm pushing for women I really
think we need to have some understanding
for why guy like like the real question
is why are guys going to this extreme of
measures and this is and why are you so
angry talking about vasectomies when
it's a small it's a very small minority
of men that get them where 90 of women
have been on birth control only four
percent of women are virgins on their
wedding days so really uh before you
start shaming the men maybe ask maybe
they're not getting married because of
the lack of wives on the market